she told the jury that she had only ever
done her best to care for the babies who
were being treated at the Countess of
Chester Hospital and the babies that of
course are at the center of this trial
this is the opening of the defense case
today and it is the first time that the
jury have heard from Lucy letby directly
and she sat in the middle of the Court
flanked by two female security officers
and she was sworn in at 10 30 this
morning and has been straight to the
point in terms of answering questions
about the impact of the allegations that
she has faced and some of her background
as well and she started by explaining
that she grew up in Hereford and then
moved to Chester to start studying a
three-year degree course at the
University of Chester and she explained
that there was a split in her course
around 50 50 between clinical placements
that the majority of which were carried
out at the contest of Chester and then
of course all the other a coursework and
study that goes along with a degree and
she said that the majority of her
clinical placements were at the Countess
of Chester Hospital and then she
qualified in September 2011 and the
series of deaths that caused alarm and
questions within the unit that have
ultimately led to the trial
have started to be looked at she's been
questioned by her own defense team at
this stage of the questioning this
morning and she says that she first
became aware that she was being held
responsible for the murder of a number
of babies in September 2016 and she said
that moment was sickening I don't think
you can be accused of anything worse
than that she told the jury this morning
she says there were times in the days
and weeks after that accusation and the
the way that that sank in that she
didn't want to continue living she said
my job was my life my whole world just
stopped and she was asked in court this
morning how hard it was to cope when she
was being accused of those crimes and
you remember the charges in this case
are the murder of seven young babies in
the attempted murder of ten others she
said I think it has completely changed
everything about me the hopes I had for
the future it has just gone
Lucy letby will continue giving evidence
through the course of today here at
Manchester Crown Court the families of
the deceased babies and others involved
in this case are watching in a secondary
courtroom a live feed of proceedings but
as I say this is the first time that
Lucy leppy has spoken in front of the
jury and that evidence is expected to
continue most of today but the entire
trial still has several weeks to run